[Music]
banquet is the easiest
safest and simplest way for you to give
food to a food bank
when you donate we take your gift
combine it with others donations
buy in bulk so we get people more of the
things they need
when they need them we of course wish
that food banks didn't exist
but whilst they do we want to support
their amazing work
and help them help more people
[Music]
chatterbox has been the home of this
place talent for four
years we want to celebrate the charter
box family
the 160 refugees 3
000 students and 20 companies around the
world
who believe in us who expanded their
minds and horizons with us
we couldn't do this without you
you are changing the world one language
lesson
at the time
ethical angel is a virtual marketplace
where global courses like charities
social enterprises and impact
entrepreneurs can order hundreds of
digital services
for free including graphic design
copywriting
social media posting logo design and
more
whether you are looking for audience
mapping to connect with new supporters
translation to share your messages with
others technical advice
to upgrade your it systems ethical angel
is the free-to-use resource you need
to get what you need with just a few
easy clicks
[Music]
we never envisioned four years ago a
global pandemic to accelerate the needs
and adoptions
by non-profits of digital solutions to
help them with their fundraising
in the first 12 weeks of covert 19 it
was estimated
that uk non-profits experienced a
shortfall in income of 4.3 billion
good box is here to change all that with
our hardware and software
we can help non-profits access the
latest in digital innovation at an
affordable cost
at the start of lockdown our team
quickly flagged up they were struggling
to work from home and one of them came
up with the idea of making a pop-up desk
within a couple of weeks we designed and
built a
design the desk built an online website
and was selling these to consumers with
nothing but five star reviews
since then companies like ryman big doug
and b and q
have all listed our products and as
people came out of lockdown
we applied our newfound confidence and
innovation to
making products like the the distancing
at work screens
and the signage we also launched a new
brand called the paper hive which was
aimed specifically at consumers
at the core what we do is help nhs
trusts and
all healthcare employers to better
manage their pool of flexible workers
through the staff bank fundamentally
reducing the reliance
on agency locums whilst ensuring
that they have a compliant pool of
workers
able to book all their vacancies and
ensuring safe staffing levels
sook has an adaptive retail space
available to book by the hour
and personalized to you pick from
sioux's growing network of locations
and bring your vision to life in an
instant with our ultra high res
digital walls from design to staffing
the entire process can be managed
remotely
whether you're based abroad or working
from home souq has got you covered
book by the hour and never pay for even
a minute more than what you need
with our flexible availability and
affordable rent
soup lets you connect with your
customers at the times that matter most
and at a price that makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
you